fractals on my mind
an epic in four parts part one the sandy
beach the three boys put on their
wellies they ran down the field they
swung on the swing they rolled down the
corn circle they came to the river they
sat on the edge dangling their feet over
the stream look bedroom a sandy beach
sure enough they saw there was a little
tiny beach of sand parents said the land
reaches down into the water and Rupert
said no the water reaches up into the
land well then it's both water and sand
it's the sandy beach it's it's a fractal
object they stood then they walked in
the stream Lucas head turns it circles
to the left
no said Rupert it circles to the right
it's turbulent flow said ruff it's a
mathematical object it's chaos on the
other side of the stream there was no
beach there was a concrete wall it was
not a fractal object
Rupert's head is a straight line parents
said this is Bauhaus expressive of
post-linguistic humanoids thinking of
peanut butter sandwiches then they
walked back up the slope Rupert said
Nature has given us a lesson nature is
our teacher and we have learned about
the sandy beach the Sun had set
Ralph's pointer to the sky look at em
they look and saw there was a silver
stripe in the sky shining there they
hadn't noticed it before
the girdled the entire celestial vault
is sprung from two lanes to the south
that way they saw that it's too late
Pierce's a survival belt
it's from across the mid heavens going
somewhere near the polar constellations
Rupert said I think those constellations
over there those are all watery that's
the Pisces the fish this well by all of
you projected on the sky current said
the the Caliban astrologers called that
the celestial sea and and Ralph said
it's it's a sandy beach in the sky our
group said father sky is our teacher too
Ralph said well there's a sphere above
the sky with the sandy beach in it and a
kind of astral projection imprinted
shadow on the celestial sphere and on
the terrestrial disc as well they went
back to the kitchen and tugged off their
wellies and looked for peanut butter in
the fridge part one the sandy beach